alexis hogue joins us now to share her
perspective
on the trial and police reform she's a
former civil rights and criminal defense
attorney
who spoke about the need for police
reform after george floyd's death
she's currently a lecturer at columbia
law school good morning to you alexis
you know this is one of them i'm hanging
in there this is one of those cases
where it's even worse than you thought
we thought it was 8 46
that was bad now we know that it's 9 29
which is
beyond description and disturbing they
played the full tape for the jury
yesterday what kind of impact do you
think that that will have
that had a strong impact and this is a
case in which
the jurors will be focused on the
evidence presented in the courtroom
and of course as lay people we have seen
this video
it is striking to us during jury
selection we learned that not every
juror
had seen the video and now they have and
so here we are
on the same page with the jurors and we
learned new evidence
in the opening three witnesses that came
forward from the state
uh this is by no means though an open
and closed
case yeah i think that's an important
point to make people think you look at
that video some would call it a slam
dunk
the first witness was the 911 operator
who effectively called police on police
we heard the mixed martial
artist guy also talking pleading with
police still despite that
experts are saying this is no guarantee
and they're referring to the rodney king
case
what do you say exactly and and that's
where
um my thoughts went immediately i am
from southern california
i remember that video uh and of course
the acquittal that happened in ventura
county
and i think that is relevant today uh
what the defense told us
is that they will be de-centering this
case away from derek shoving
instead they're going to be looking at
the training and the policies of the
minneapolis police department and also
the chaos
and the threat that came from the crowd
is the way that they characterized it
and we keep hearing now that the police
chief is
is expected to testify against one of
his officers
highly highly highly unusual what effect
will that happen
on this particular case it has a
significant impact what's on trial here
is really the use of force
the legality of the use of force and the
appropriateness of the use of force
and so when you have the police chief
saying that this
knee to the neck technique is not
approved
that provides some additional context
however i want to make clear to our
viewers gail
that the knee to the neck is an
allowable use of force in minneapolis
it was removed from many police
departments in minnesota
but it is allowed as a use of force in
this city so this will be a critical
witness
well they say prosecutor opened very
strong he said you can believe your uh
what your eyes are telling you this was
a case of murder
we will see the jury of course will have
the final say on that alexis hope we
thank you very much for joining us this
morning